Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Carole Bertaux :
Aimer est-il votre priorité ?
Anvesh Tirupathi : Il y a dix ans,
je ne parlais pas anglais.
Je ne parlais pas français.
Je ne voyageais pas.
Et quand j’étais petit,
j’étais très mauvais à l’école.
Mais je m’intéressais déjà beaucoup
au dessin, à la peinture et au théâtre.
Je m’appelle Anvesh.
Je suis artiste,
je suis indien.
Dans mon pays,
il y a 22 langues officielles.
Moi je parle le télougou,
c’est ma langue maternelle.
Je viens d’un village du l’Inde du sud.
J'ai eu une petite famille.
Nous sommes quatre, avec mon frère.
Nous sommes très soudés.
En Inde,
le mariage, c’est très important,
c’est vraiment important.
D’ailleurs, mes parents pensent
toujours à mon avenir.
La logique dans mon pays,
c’est rester dans son État,
trouver du travail,
se marier avec une fille
qui parle ta langue,
qui comprend par culture
et qui vit avec tes parents
sous le même toit.
En Inde, c'est normal.
CB : Je m’appelle Carole.
Je suis photographe.
Je suis française.
Petite, je rêvais d'être artiste.
Je voulais aller dans une école d’art
et tout apprendre :
le dessin, la peinture,
la sculpture, la vidéo.
Ma famille est là pour m'encourager.
Ma motivation principale dans la vie,
c'est d'être libre, forte, indépendante.
Pas question de se marier.
En 2009, je suis aux Beaux-Arts,
je vais à une exposition
sur la culture indienne.
J'y retourne trois fois.
Il se passe quelque chose.
L’Inde.
Je me documente et l’idée d’y aller
devient une idée fixe.
Avec l’aide de mon école,
je monte un programme d’échange
d’une durée de six mois
avec une école d’art indienne.
J’y arrive en août 2011
et rien que le nom de l’école,
je vais mettre quelques semaines
pour parvenir à le prononcer :
Karnataka Chitrakala Parishat.
AT : Karnataka Chitrakala Parishat.
(Rires)
C'est aussi l'école que j'ai choisie.
Et je suis content.
Mon père accepte les études que j’aime,
mais je ne parle pas
la langue de cet État ni anglais.
C'est très difficile parce que je ne peux
pas comprendre les professeurs.
Et la directrice m’a dit
de chercher une autre école.
J'ai envie d'abandonner.
Un jour, je vois Carole.
À ce moment-là , je ne pense plus
à mon problème de langue.
(Rires)
Je l'aime beaucoup.
Je pense seulement à elle
et je veux lui parler.
Alors, je demande à la directrice
trois mois de plus
pour apprendre l’anglais.
Et elle accepte.
J’apprends l’anglais en regardant
des films de Hollywood,
Dollywood, Bollywood, Kollywood,
sous-titrés.
CB : Je me fais des amis à l’école,
surtout un.
Anvesh est dans ma classe,
il est toujours prêt à m’aider.
J’ai beaucoup de mal
à comprendre les cours, lui aussi.
Alors très vite, une forte
complicité s'installe.
Dans un anglais bourré de fautes.
Mais on se comprend.
On se comprend tellement bien
et on passe tellement de temps ensemble
que, curieusement, on tombe amoureux.
Quelques semaines avant mon retour
pour la France, on se met ensemble.
Même pas peur.
Dès que j’atterris sur le sol français,
je ne pense qu’à une chose :
organiser mon prochain voyage
pour revoir Anvesh.
AT : Pendant son voyage en 2012,
Carole veut que je vienne en France.
Mais je ne sais pas comment faire
pour que mes parents acceptent.
Ils la connaissent.
Mais j’ai besoin de leur permission,
car en Inde, nous accordons beaucoup
d’importance et de respect aux parents.
Et finalement, ils acceptent.
Tous mes amis pensent que mon voyage
va être comme celui de Mister Bean.
J’apprends « Bonjour »,
j’apprends « Merci ».
J’apprends « Désolé ».
J’apprends l’avion.
J’apprends les toilettes de l’avion.
J'apprends que je ne sais rien.
Et en plus, je ne parle pas bien anglais.
Et finalement tout se passe bien.
J'atterris en France.
Je rencontre la famille de Carole.
Je découvre la France.
Nous visitons beaucoup d'expositions
et nous nous aimons.
CB : Je retourne en Inde l’été suivant.
On passe de très bons moments,
mais il faut encore se quitter,
se dire au revoir à l’aéroport.
Quand on se dit au revoir,
c’est pour une durée inconnue.
C'est déjà la quatrième fois.
De retour en France, je me mets
à fond dans mes études.
Je fais des stages
pour préparer mon avenir.
Je ne sais pas
quand je vais revoir Anvesh.
Nous sommes étudiants, nous sommes fauchés
et sans projet d’avenir
qui implique d’être ensemble.
Mon cœur est sec, déchiré par
tous ces adieux aux aéroports.
124 jours après notre dernier au revoir,
je me protège et je décide de mettre fin
à notre relation à distance
et je le fais à distance.
AT : Moi, je continue à rester en contact
avec elle, avec ses amis.
Je continue à envoyer
des messages, beaucoup.
Après, j’ai arrêté.
Je commence à travailler,
je fais des petits films,
je fais des storyboard pour le cinéma
de Bollywood.
CB : De mon côté, j’obtiens mon diplôme,
je travaille, je fais des rencontres.
L’envie de mener un nouveau projet
grandit, car l’Inde me manque beaucoup.
Ça fait quatre ans.
J'aimerais y réaliser un projet
artistique personnel.
J'obtiens une bourse pour un projet photo.
Je contacte Anvesh pour le revoir
et passer du temps ensemble.
AT : Quinze jours avant son arrivée
en Inde, Carole me contacte et me dit
qu’elle veut me revoir
pour m’associer à son projet.
J’accepte et je suis très content.
(Rires)
CB : On passe quelques jours ensemble.
On parle beaucoup de nos vies,
de la vie en général.
Je suis sereine.
J’ai réussi à mener à bien mon projet,
mais je dois encore une fois
refaire mes valises.
AT : Avec mon frère,
nous déposons Carole au bus.
C'est la saison des pluies.
Je suis sous la pluie
et Carole est dans le bus.
Je suis très triste qu’elle parte.
Et je ne sais pas
quand nous nous reverrons.
À ce moment-là, je sens
qu’elle est la seule pour moi.
La seule femme que je veux dans ma vie.
Alors je monte dans le bus.
Je lui ai dit :
«Je vais venir te voir bientôt.»
Après son départ,
je parle à mes parents et je leur dis
que Carole est la femme de ma vie.
Je veux me marier avec elle.
Rappelez-vous en Inde, le mariage,
c’est très important, vraiment important.
D’abord, c’est non.
Et puis, petit à petit, en expliquant,
en prenant le temps,
ils comprennent ma détermination.
Et finalement, ils acceptent
que j’aille en France.
Ils me disent même que tout ira bien.
Là, je commence à m’organiser
sans l’aide de Carole.
Ça me demande beaucoup de temps.
C'est très difficile.
Il me faudra plus d'un an.
Avec mes amis,
nous avons d’ailleurs un groupe WhatsApp
qui s’appelle Mission Seventy Seven Days.
J’ai 77 jours pour demander
Carole en mariage.
CB : Je ne sais rien
de la mission des 77 jours.
Je pense seulement à recevoir un ami,
donc il dormira dans le salon.
AT : Carole est distante
pendant longtemps.
Mon ami me Nagomé et me dit :
«Fais-lui à manger, elle t’écoutera.»
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
En fait, cette idée
a très bien fonctionné.
(Rires)
Avec mes talents de cuisinier,
elle accepte de discuter.
Nous partageons notre vision
de la cuisine et de la vie.
Nous nous rapprochons.
Et je lui explique combien
elle est importante pour moi.
Un jour, je lui fais ma demande.
Elle accepte ma demande - mission réussie.
CB : Lorsque j’accepte,
je sais que ma vie va changer.
On s’attaque à une montagne.
Si la demande d’Anvesh est touchante,
moi, je suis directement plongée
dans les responsabilités
et les conséquences de cette union.
Et pourtant, je suis sûre de ma réponse.
Ce sera oui.
Je sais que, désormais,
nous tiendrons la distance.
Il n'y a pas de doute.
Nous décidons de vivre en France.
Pour cela, il faut qu’Anvesh apprenne
le français et obtienne un visa.
Après avoir travaillé dur, il est accepté
au Centre international de Rennes
où je vis et travaille.
Lorsque le premier visa est rejeté,
nous pensons
qu’il faut renforcer le dossier.
Après une semaine,
Anvesh dépose sa seconde demande.
Six heures - après 6 h,
son visa est rejeté.
Le motif ?
« Votre séjour a d’autres
fins que les études. »
Bon, avec le recul,
ils n’avaient pas tout à fait tort.
(Rires)
Mais à ce moment-là, nous sommes dépités
et surtout, nous sommes au pied du mur.
Pour être ensemble,
il faut nous marier en Inde.
J’ai dit oui à Anvesh
car je connais sa culture.
Je sais que sans le mariage,
nous ne pourrons pas vivre ensemble.
Je n'ai informé personne.
Je voulais attendre, attendre qu’Anvesh
connaisse mieux ma famille, mes amis,
faire les choses en douceur,
à l’occidentale.
Mais quand on aime, on fait des choix,
on prend des risques, on les assume.
AT : Je suis le fils aîné et mes parents
veulent un grand mariage.
En Inde, le mariage, c’est un spectacle.
Tout le monde est invité.
Les voisins, les collègues, les amis,
les connaissances et la famille bien sûr.
On arrive facilement
à 400 ou 500 personnes.
Mais à ce moment-là, Carole et moi,
nous voulons juste être ensemble.
Nous ne pensons pas à faire la fête.
Et finalement, mes parents
comprennent la situation.
Donc, nous nous marions en petit comité,
nous sommes huit au bureau des mariages.
Personne d’autre n’est informé.
Mes parents annoncent
les fiançailles à la famille
et nous ferons une grande fête plus tard.
CB : Alors que je suis mariée civilement
en Inde depuis quelques heures,
je reçois un message
de la compagnie aérienne.
Mon vol de retour
pour la France est annulé.
Nous sommes en 2020,
c’est le début de la pandémie.
Je suis en sari, en tenue traditionnelle.
Le prêtre prépare
la cérémonie des fiançailles.
Une trentaine de personnes attendent.
L’ambassade me recommande
de partir tout de suite.
Vraiment tout de suite.
C'est trop dur, je ne peux pas.
Je décide donc de rester
car je suis avec Anvesh,
je suis en famille, je suis en sécurité.
Je compte sur le fait de trouver
une solution dans les jours qui viennent.
Je vais finalement rester un peu
plus de cinq mois en Inde,
accueillie les bras ouverts
par les parents d’Anvesh.
AT : Puisque Carole a décidé de rester,
je sais que nous allons vivre
ensemble avec ma famille.
Comme ça, elle peut comprendre ma culture.
C’est inespéré.
(Rires)
Je suis très heureux.
Et mes parents aussi.
Et finalement,
grâce à la pandémie,
nous pouvons vivre ensemble.
CB : Le contexte incertain me fait
réaliser qu’à quelques jours près,
nous aurions pu ne pas nous marier.
Après treize mois à distance,
après 416 jours sans pouvoir se voir,
j’aurais pu ne pas prendre l’avion,
à quinze jours près.
Finalement, le quotidien banal
dont je rêvais avec Anvesh,
c’est là, en Inde, en plein confinement,
que nous le vivions.
Alors on décide de ne plus se quitter.
Les démarches, on les fera ensemble
et c’est ensemble que
nous rentrerons en France.
(Parle en télougou)
Cette citation de l’écrivain Srirangam
Srinivasa Rao a beaucoup inspiré Anvesh,
n’est-ce pas ?
AT : Si tu veux quelque chose,
pour ça, tu peux courir.
Si tu ne peux pas courir, tu peux marcher.
Si tu ne peux pas marcher, tu peux ramper.
Mais ne reste pas où tu es.
C'est très inspirant pour moi.
Dans mon enfance,
on me disait de travailler dur
je travaillais dur et je n’y arrivais pas.
Mais quand j’ai aimé,
tout est devenu plus facile.
Maintenant, je parle anglais.
Maintenant, je vis en France.
Maintenant, j'apprends le français.
Maintenant, je fais un TEDx en français.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Ma femme ne vit pas avec mes parents.
Elle ne vient pas de mon village.
Et même si je suis d’une autre culture,
c’est dans la famille de Carole
que je me fais une place.
Je pense que l’amour apprend à tout
le monde à être patient et tolérant.
Merci pour ça.
CB : Oui, merci pour ça.
C’est l’amour qui m’a aidée à affirmer
mes choix, à affronter mes peurs,
même les plus viscérales,
comme celle de ne plus être aimée
parce que j’aimais.
L'amour, c'est devenu notre boussole.
C'est aussi devenu celle de nos proches.
Par amour pour nous,
ils ont accepté le nôtre.
Pas besoin de péripéties, pas besoin de
Bollywood, pas besoin de 6000 kilomètres
pour faire de l’amour votre priorité.
Parfois, au coin de la rue,
c’est déjà un choix,
une décision que vous avez à prendre.
La persévérance permet
d’obtenir du bonheur
dans chaque petit moment de la vie.
L'amour rend fort.
Il permet d’affirmer vos choix de vie
et il permet de grandir.
AT : C’est chaque jour que
nous cherchons à comprendre.
Comprendre nos familles,
comprendre nos amis
et surtout se comprendre pour nous aimer.
Ça, c’est notre priorité.
Je vous remercie.
CB : Oui, je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)